thank you yaser and here I'm really with
a special guest ala fua is here with us
welcome ala ala is the winner of the
previous St Louis rapit and bit event
how do you feel yourself here today we
have changed the planing venue and we
play today in the Hall of Fame how did
it go yeah the set of the feeling of the
playing Hall is the same I feel like he
changed the playe hall but the feeling
of the chess board and everything is
same so it's not big change but yeah and
I feel happy with my play I think it was
a decent day I could have maybe pushed
last game more but other than that it
was a good day I think especially I had
two blacks yeah yeah you started with
two black pieces and your Victory
against Fab I think it was really
amazing I mean this um opposite castling
yes position maybe you can show a little
bit what was happening there it's very
typical that after H3 white cannot
Castle short so it's very safe to Castle
long and um so you felt that your attack
will be faster right yeah and probably
here he has to just go for equal
position with Knight C4 takes takes and
Bishop C5 and is's very equal but he
want he was ambitious here mhm and
decided to go for this for this position
and but I'm always faster because I have
two Bishops and Knight H5 Knight F4 is
really quick he has to push here but it
takes a lot of time so you like your
position here uh I knew the position so
it's very typical and it was it was a
very like it was a very easy game
actually because my moves were very
straightforward mhm and he was taking
his time to make some mess like some
complication but it's not easy because
you're getting M yeah you're just I
don't know nothing is happening on the
side right it feels like always you have
some AB sacrifice the bishop but Queen
is always protecting so yeah I mean B6
could look weak but it's not yeah so
here he has to give up his second bishop
and then yeah this is I'm attacking for
free I'm not even sacrificing anything
so um yeah he slowly slowly here just it
was
very easy game could expect expected you
know in the first round against Fabby to
win with black pieces like that beat Fab
in this Berlin line three four times
actually with black yeah candidates also
I don't know why he goes against it
always this against me but he feels like
he's always
has we have some questions to Fab to ask
later yes but yeah I mean it went
smoothly for you the the second game
finished in a draw right against Jeffrey
Jun and um there was some repetition you
had black pieces and then okay the last
round you play against your compatriot
Maxim V gra and um with white pieces
finally what do you think you you had
you had some oh you decided to avoid
open C right yeah yeah I mean Maxine is
very well prepared so and I have a good
score in the tournament so I didn't need
to
uh r or something much yes so I decided
to choose a very solid line but um this
is a very old Theory and I couldn't
remember what was the what were the
details but I think yes so maybe it was
perfect game but yeah it seemed like
actually a computer is happy with both
of you but let's say whether any moment
in this game you felt that you could
have something um I felt like but this
is Theory probably stupid to say I felt
like here I have good chance but I felt
here we could try some other moves but
the pieces got exchanged yeah and the
end it was just actually I mean so many
trades followed up yeah Al is such a
great start for you I mean do you feel
really good I mean to be here to come
back yeah it feels really great uh the
everything is perfect the playing Hall
they really managed to make it
professional so um until here I'm very
happy but we'll see how it'll go yeah
exactly all the best of luck for you and
we are going back to the studio thank
you Anastasia thank you uh Ali r